this video is very applicable to anyone
with a problem with their bladder
whether it's
urinary
urgency okay leaky bladder incomplete
urination or frequent urination or you
get up several times at night this video
is for you and unfortunately when you do
a Google search on this topic
you're going to find pure trash okay all
of these sites that you go to
say almost the exact same thing and what
they do is they just hire search engine
optimization people SEO people to write
articles these people have no experience
but they just get the keywords and they
create articles and then they rank on
Google so it's extremely difficult to
find anything valuable
on Google relating to health information
especially the bladder and unless you
know what to search for and some
possible links it's very very difficult
I have the advantage of just have been
in practice for 30 years so I've seen
things that I would never have
connected the dots unless I had that
practical experience so when we talk
about the urinary bladder we're talking
about
um
a muscle that stores
urine and releases urine so we have this
muscle that surrounds your bladder okay
it's called the nutrition muscle and if
we look at the Common Thread to all
these bladder problems it's actually a
problem with the nervous system I'm
going to explain why we have a valvular
system that's controlled and then also
involves smooth muscle as well as the
neurological Supply and the main control
with urine elimination really stems from
your brain it's called periaqueductal
gray matter not that you need to know
that but there's a part of the brain
that is in control of this bladder okay
and then connects to the nervous system
and this part of the brain is very
vulnerable and sensitive
to a thymine deficiency a B1 deficiency
in fact other parts of the autonomic
nervous system that's involved with this
bladder control are also very vulnerable
to vitamin B1 deficiencies I found some
fascinating information which I share
Down Below in the description on the
link the very strong link between a B1
deficiency and your bladder problem that
you're having right now whether the
bladder is overworking or underworking
B1 seems to be
Common Thread and this also makes sense
if you look at a diabetic right when
we're talking about Diabetes Type 2
there's like 50 to 70 percent of those
people who have bladder problems now if
you watch some of my other videos you
saw this huge connection between
diabetes and peripheral neuropathy
problems okay I'm talking about the the
numbness the bottom of the feet or the
pain the bottom of the feet relates to a
B1 deficiency I've done other videos on
diabetics having just general problems
with their autonomic nervous system and
there's a name for that diabetic
autonomic neuropathy so anytime you have
a problem with neuropathies like nerve
problems
you really want to look at this B1
because there's a huge connection
B1 is involved in the myelin sheath
production around the nerve and B1 is
also necessary for the production of
energy especially if it's from
carbohydrates or glucose and so the more
carbohydrates or glucose that are used
by the body okay the more B1 is needed
now a B1 deficiency in the brain can
even starve off the energies of certain
neurons in the brain and cause a lack of
function in those brain neurons as in
this case that part of the brain that
controls the bladder actually is
shrinking and you're losing function of
the entire control system and this can
be a very common thing when we age
especially if someone's a diabetic a
pre-diabetic or they have chronic
insulin resistance which is very common
it's like 60 to 70 percent of the
population and this is another reason
why so many people get so much relief
when they start to cut the carbs out of
the diet and a relief with bladder
issues so it is true that your bladder
problems could be coming from let's say
a prostate enlargement or a prolapsed
bladder if you're a female or you have
disinfection in your bladder or of
course you're drinking way too much
water before you go to bed or you have I
don't know fibroid whatever all of these
are valid but there's something a lot
more common involved in all of these
bladder issues and that is a B1
deficiency and if you don't know that
okay you may end up at the doctor's
office
getting more medication maybe a surgery
and not fully fixing this problem so
here are some simple things you can do
you need to First correct the B1
deficiency and I would recommend
correcting it with two different types
of B1 one is a fat soluble B1 called
benphotamine and two is a natural
water-soluble regular B1 but you want to
make sure it's natural not synthetic and
I would take both of these remedies for
about two to three months okay because
if you are very very deficient it's
going to take a while to build up but
for most people they should start seeing
Improvement within the first two weeks
now number two you want to stop the
depleting of B1 there's many things that
can deplete B1 but the most common thing
is a high carb diet so you need to get
on a low carb diet okay and that also
includes doing intermittent fasting now
the next thing you can do which I highly
recommend
is based on this you have two types of
receptors in the bladder okay for urine
you have mechanical receptors which
involve pressure or volume of urine okay
but you also have
chemoreceptors which involve the
concentration of urine
so for example if you don't have a lot
of urine because maybe you're not
drinking a lot your urine can be very
very concentrated and despite having a
lot of urine you might just need to go
yet when you go not a lot comes out so
just by drinking enough fluid through
the day and I'm talking about like two
and a half liters of fluid not past
six or seven o'clock at night okay you
can dilute the urine to the point where
the need for urination is less at night
and you can also try that as well in
addition to drinking this extra water
you may also benefit from adding apple
cider vinegar to your water why because
apple cider vinegar can greatly help
your blood sugars okay especially if you
have insulin resistance I've done a lot
of videos on this apple cider vinegar is
like a real simple thing to do you put
one to two tablespoons in your water
when you drink it and it can greatly
help your blood sugars and then you
might find based on how much caffeine
you consume is to reduce the caffeine
beverages to maybe a small cup of coffee
in the morning but not a lot of coffee
that has caffeine because the caffeine
can really affect your bladder in a big
way and just by reducing your caffeine
that can to make a huge difference now
the last thing I would recommend is to
manually massage the bladder okay why
because your bladder over time can be
congested it could be atrophied and if
you press into your bladder within your
tolerance and just kind of massage
around that area and then you might find
that you need to urinate right after
that I used to recommend this in
practice and it really helped stimulate
the bladder to actually get more tone
into the bladder and to help push out
some of the residual urine that could be
potentially sitting in your bladder for
too long now there are many other things
that can cause a B1 deficiency Beyond
just sugar and carbs okay
and I really highly recommend that you
watch this video on that topic right
here